- Kali is having a picnic
for her six friends.
The oldest friend,
Vikram, is 10 years old.
The youngest, Diya, is six years old.
She has a total of 48 blueberries
and wants to split them evenly
between her friends.
How many blueberries does each friend get?
And I encourage you to now,
pause this video
and try to figure it out on your own.
How many blueberries does each friend get?
Let's think about this a little bit.
So she has six friends.
She has six friends
and she wants them all
to be able to get the same amount.
So, she wants to split
the 48 blueberries evenly
amongst her six friends.
The ages of her friends don't matter.
So, she's going to take
the 48 blueberries.
She's going to take the 48 blueberries
and divide it,
and divide it
by six.
She wants to divide it into six groups.
So she wants to divide it into six groups.
48 divided by 6.
And so this,
so question mark,
is going to be equal to
the number of blueberries
that each friend gets.
So 48 divided by six is
equal to question mark,
is the same thing as saying
that 48,
48 is equal to,
is equal to question mark times six,
times six.
So if we could figure out
what number we can multiply by six
to get 48,
then we know what 48 divided by six
actually is.
For example, this question mark,
this is the number of
blueberries per friend.
The number of blueberries
per friend times six friends,
well that should tell us the
total number of blueberries,
which is 48.
So what is this number?
Well, let's think about,
let's just think about
all of the multiples of six.
So, six times one is equal to six.
Six times two is equal to 12.
And really we're just
increasing by six each time.
We're just increasing by six.
Six times three is equal to 18.
Six times four is equal to 24.
Six times five is equal to 30.
Six times six is equal to 36.
Six times seven is equal to 42.
Notice we're just adding six every time.
Six times eight is equal to 48.
Is equal to 48.
So we now know that question mark,
we now know that the
question mark must be eight.
Six times eight
and eight times six is the same thing.
So this is going to be equal
to six times question mark.
Six times question mark
and now we learned
that question mark is equal to 48.
Sorry, question mark is equal to eight.
So, each of her friends
are going to get eight blueberries.
So this is, right over here,
48 divided by six is equal
to eight blueberries.
Now, let's verify that.
We have 48 blueberries right over here.
Lets divide them into six groups
where each group is going
to have eight blueberries.
So let me do my best.
So let's see, this is one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
So, that's a group of eight blueberries.
See, here's another group
of eight blueberries,
right over here.
And there's another
group, right over here,
of eight blueberries.
And then, here's our fourth group
And now, let's see,
we can make a fifth group
of eight blueberries.
Fifth group of eight blueberries.
And then, finally,
here is our sixth group.
Here is our sixth group
of eight blueberries.
So notice,
we have six groups of eight blueberries.
Each of her six friends
could take one of these groups
of eight blueberries.